watching atheists wake up to reality is
like watching a newborn baby open his
eyes for the first time the light is
painful when all you've ever known is
Darkness inside a protective womb that
Shields you from the outside world but
after a brief painful transition your
eyes will eventually adjust ion hery Ali
is on an amazing journey I read her
books the Caged virgin and Infidel many
years ago following her apostasy from
Islam aan has been closely associated
with all of the main figures among the
new atheists but she's been going
through some changes recently if you
listen to her you'll hear her saying
things like god-given I think power is a
given it's it's like the law of gravity
and uh there's also powerlessness and
none of us wants to be powerless um but
there is god-given
natural power Ian hery Ali has god-given
power it helped her Escape Islam and now
it's helping her escape the new atheism
this clip is from a recent panel
discussion with Jordan Peterson Oz
Guinness John Anderson and of course Ian
hery Ali they're discussing the
significance of stories big stories
stories about our place in the world I
watched it after rousin posted some of
what ion said ion is going through a
transition that I've been seeing over
and over and over again people who just
a decade or so ago were extremely
hostile to Christianity or religion in
general are starting to warm up to some
very religious Concepts suddenly they
start talking about the Transcendent
something Beyond
ourselves and it's very arrogant to
assume that you can change human beings
to fit into all sorts of modules
therefore you accept that there is a
power Transcendent above us a power
Transcendent above us a power
Transcendent above us that doesn't sound
like atheism so where are you getting
this
Transcendent whatever above us and that
idea that there is something above us a
higher power I think
that that is rooted in Christianity it's
rooted in the judeo-christian
Traditions you're getting this trans
Transcendent higher power from
Christianity why would anyone go with
something from Christianity instead of
atheism and in many ways it is superior
to the nihilistic init type
um atheistic
theology um that human beings can do and
they can create everything and they can
they can manipulate wait the
judeo-christian concept of God is
Superior in many ways to
atheism now she specifically refers to a
n type atheism where once you reject
Christianity you give up Christian
morality and therefore you need to
replace Christian morality with
something else but here nche was just
being way way more realistic and common
sensical than lots of other atheists
German philosophers were better at
understanding the implications of
rejecting Christianity than British
philosophers were German philosophers
said if we're getting rid of God and
Christianity then everything that's been
built upon a foundation of God and
Christianity is about to come tumbling
to the ground so we need a new morality
with a New Foundation a few decades
later World War
II British philosophers by contrast said
we don't need God and Christianity to
have our moral views look at us atheists
see how moral we are we're walking proof
that people don't need God and
Christianity what these super smart
atheists weren't smart enough to grasp
was that they were all raised in places
that taught them Christian values they
didn't come up with anything on their
own they absorbed their values from
their
culture and their morality was like a
rose that had been cut yes it may be
beautiful but the beauty is going to
fade because a cut Rose Dies so I don't
see how Ian's Claim about the Christian
concept of God being Superior to a nich
type atheism wouldn't be true about
Atheism in general but she says that the
judeo-christian concept of the
Transcendent is also Superior to
something else and it's also Superior I
would say to the faith that I grew up in
um with a God and a Theology and a story
that gives individuals a sort of
onedimensional purpose go and do this
make everyone a Muslim and if they
refuse kill them and then the day of
judgment will come and life will be over
that's a simple story but it's it's an
abiding story it's been around for 14400
years better than Islam to be
fair pretty much anything is better than
Islam isn't it the judeo-christian
tradition that it is not up to the human
being to do that but all we can do is
civilize and continue to civilize and
question and check power power that is
checked that is the power that
guarantees most people real Freedom the
judeo-christian tradition is what
guarantees real Freedom does this sound
like the atheists from 10 years ago
Jordan Peterson goes on to ask about
ion's Journey from from Islam so you
early in your life relatively early in
your life you moved away from a um a
totalizing religious view of the world
Islam I don't exactly know into what you
then moved whether that was a secular
humanism but what I'm hearing from you
now and and I I believe this is also the
case with your husband is that you have
come
to to a new understanding understanding
of the existence of the Transcendent per
se and also of your relationship with
him she moved away from the Islamic view
of the Transcendent to a rejection of
the Transcendent to a new understanding
of the Transcendent so I rebelled
against a Transcendent a concept of God
of a God that now manifests itself in
you know the Iranian regime um Hamas
Isis that was the god I grew up with
that was the story that I grew up with I
rebelled against that she rebelled
specifically against the Islamic concept
of the
Transcendent and then when I uh was bold
enough to say and this was in the
Netherlands um I I don't want any of
that I didn't convert to Christianity I
didn't convert to another religion or
another God pay attention because this
is true of many ex-muslims once they've
witnessed the horrors of the god of
Muhammad they don't want another God I
carried with me this idea uh the you
know the three letter word of God stands
just for evil they move away from Islam
but when they hear the word God all they
think of is evil and my best friends
became Sam Harris and Christopher
Hitchens and Richard Dawkins these are
people I still love and adore we all
love and adore these guys they performed
one of the greatest social experiments
in history what happens if you start to
remove Christianity from Western
Civilization their theory was that if
you remove Christianity you get an
atheist Utopia where science and reason
reign
supreme how's that experiment working
out for everyone and I think over time
I'm now 53 and so when I made this when
I was in this state of rebellion it
started for me when I was 32 years old
over time I've come to realize and I
wish Christopher was alive today to
comment on what we are going through I
wish Christopher Hitchens were here to
see this too I would love to hear his
thoughts on the catastrophic failure of
everything the new atheists promised but
what did Aon come to realize we were
actually having a conversation
about in my view The Wrong conversation
does God exist you know it was the world
built in six days uh do we believe in
fairy tales and that was the wrong
conversation to have so a conversation
about whether various claims are true or
false this is the wrong
conversation what's the right
conversation the right conversation to
have as I said earlier was to compare
what we as human beings the
Transcendent that we have imagined and
developed over centuries so The Wrong
conversation is are these claims that
are part of the judeo-christian
tradition true the right conversation is
how does the concept or the story of the
Transcendent that has developed in the
judeo Christian tradition match up
against other Concepts or other stories
and here it sounds like she's thinking
in purely practical pragmatic terms what
does this view lead to what does that
view lead to so which view is better now
I think we can have both conversations I
think we can discuss whether various
claims are true while also discussing
what these claims lead to and having
both conversations leads to a further
conversation namely how does our
realization that a certain story
produces far better results affect our
view of whether that story is true but
let's see where Aon is going with this
and so now I can say I am proudly of
judeo Christian religion aan hery Ali an
ex-muslim who has spent many years as a
devout atheist now identifies as a
member of the judeo-christian
religion without having to waste your
time about do I really think that the
world was was built in six days do I
really believe every word in the Bible
no but I do believe that that judeo
Christian tradition and what it has
brought
forth is those are the values that I
aspire to the values by which I live so
without believing that certain
propositions within the judeo-christian
tradition are true she nevertheless
realizes that she's part of the
tradition and that she wants to be part
of the tradition
not exactly someone Christians would
recognize as a fellow follower of Jesus
Christ but in a way she is in a way she
is following Jesus and we can at least
appreciate the change in such a short
amount of time from Christianity is
terrible for the world and needs to be
replaced by atheism to pump your brakes
everyone turns out we may need
Christianity way more than we thought I
was called a Christian by Roger Roger
scrutin in 2008 and I said Roger no I'm
not a Christian and he said but you act
like a Christian and you behave like a
Christian therefore you are a Christian
she was living like a Christian even
when she despised
Christianity and she's not the only one
and I think that is that's exactly what
I would like to say to Richard Dawkins
it's you act like I've been to you know
Coral music with him which he enjoys
very much and he's one of most Christian
people I know Richard Dawkins is one of
the most Christian people ion knows what
does she mean by this Dawkins doesn't
even believe in God what does she
mean she means that Dawkins has been
massively influenced by Christianity and
that he's living according to Christian
values that he absorbed from a Christian
culture even though he uses the values
that he absorbed from a a Christian
culture to condemn and mock the source
of these values the leaders of the new
atheism Richard Dawkins Christopher
Hitchens Daniel Dennett Sam Harris they
Rose to prominence in the ivarest of all
Ivory Towers they looked at themselves
in their glorious Tower and said hey
we're very nice people we're champions
of virtue we love science we're not
killing each other over
disagreements why are we so
amazing then they looked at the rest of
the world and said check out all these
Savages why are they so different from
us why are they so dumb why are they
blowing each other
up oh it must be because these other
people are religious so if we just get
rid of religion everyone will be like
us that was one of the the most insanely
idiotic and delusional conclusions in
the history of humanity and it came from
people who regard themselves as pillars
of
rationality fortunately like all
scientifically minded men they put
together an experiment just start
replacing Christianity with atheism and
the entire world will be able to observe
Society becoming more and more rational
more and more logical more and more
scientific more and more ethical that's
what will happen if we start removing
Christianity and we all know what
actually happened the moment people
started turning away from Christianity
the entire world started going
completely
insane so the grand experiment of the
new atheists which they thought would
confirm atheism and lead to an atheist
Utopia did the exact
opposite now if our atheist friends are
really as scientifically minded as they
claim how should they react as their
theories are being debunked as surely as
Alchemy and spontaneous generation and
fistan and phenology and a static
universe will they abandon their
discredited and debunked position as Aon
and many others are doing or will they
cling to The Atheist delusion by 100%
uncut unadulterated grade A
Blind
[Music]
Faith